hello and welcome to this video playing
caps 2015 the room I can go for the brea
even though I haven't haven't studied it
yet I've got that Victor Borge on book
but I'm not quite sure if I'm really
shooting for that to be honest it is a
good line but I'm also thinking about
maybe looking at something entirely
different in there is something that I
maybe um yeah study myself not with the
use of a book like writing myself about
it or something like that I haven't
really made my mind up yet but I felt
that with this this the project with the
names of bogo Indian I felt that if you
yeah if you study it yourself and yeah
on a level that you actually can write a
book about it you really afterwards know
what you need to know about the opening
it's just all so more interesting than
just studying something that is
basically a page six yep that is some
already pre produced for you if you do
it yourself it's often an interest more
interesting process
yeah in recent years and it has become
quite common that white takes on c5 in
some cases and I wasn't quite sure if
this is something that he could have
done here this is why I went to cook
night ft 7 I happen to have lots of
pieces on the queenside I'm bit worried
about age for something like that h4 h5
hmm and I probably else have to stay
here if he does that not yeah k goes
back okay I was thinking that be six now
to clarify the situation it's definitely
helpful for me if we trade trade routes
for example a five looks wrong I think
he has to take okay
I cannot tip you it's not threatening to
take the five anyway so i can go back
here
it's definitely helpful to have some
experience and those closed we positions
even if you play a line like I do here
and they don't know that well you can at
least play quickly because you know the
general ideas ok it seems he wants to go
over to a 22 before but I have a counter
play against you for now how does he
even cover that pawn it's not so easy
yeah if you have to do that something
has gone wrong ok taking what the porn
is interesting actually now but I don't
like it it's better like that I believe
no my idea is to oh I wanted to come
around with with the bishop if i take
now my be porn can be weak so I'm going
back and I have Queen a one now in some
situations and I have Bishop e78 p6 this
is the big idea what what are you doing
there buddy you want to weaken yourself
even more g4 looks like that's it sir
that's very weakening so ok this is all
v6 now you see going for g5g five now is
somewhat somewhat more more potent now I
can just go back though ok I'm ever
happy that I have the bishop now won't
be six g5 I can go back ok I don't get
it and she doing them
therefore nah wow he's really not ever
playing a backward move so how to do it
alright f3 here on the stat and either
three have queen of six as well
hmm and it's not bad between you have
six I just wonder they have something
better and yeah I think it's good
that's a pretty good endgame i-94 maybe
it's got 94 attacking my b5 pawn
and check g5 okay so Bishop over to d2
why I guess what he's doing is just
pushing everything forward and weakening
himself a lot and the process so we
should see 84 Bishop g4 and then taking
all the pawns your nite nite chief is
also not bad it's not so clear should be
49 f 3 yes I don't think I'll check
okay I think I can do this now just go
to the sea three Pawn so night cheeks is
possible 93 not sure check so how to do
that we should chief form on night back
to see three times actually good ship
situate yeah I cannot a ticket down
check check check check check check
check mate okay so let's let's have a
look there what happened it was a pretty
equal ish for a long time like here this
is this is just about equal I think
after Luke's are traded normally blacks
position is okay you have just if the
rooks are off the kind of it gets to
maneuvering phase of the game where the
space disadvantage and the center isn't
felt so much this is wrong because after
this I get get the bishops and
yeah i can now I can you know move like
g4 it just weakens white is just
weakening himself and he doesn't get any
anything for it yeah you should just
stay there and he he did that the whole
game I'm just weakening or from here
let's say or earlier f was also just bad
the idea Bishop b5 as a direct win okay
I didn't look for any tactics because
strategically speaking a black is in
fantastic shape I didn't look look for
tactics but we can look at just to check
how it wins this is the idea computer
gives this and now Queen jf six that's
neat yeah the engine says that this is
equal maybe it is with 90 form that's
possible that this is saving wide and
therefore I should have really not
played Queen f6 I can also just keep
everything as it is for 95 and so on
Bishop can come to see eight and
possibly some h5 and maybe it is not
that great but teach I kept wiggling his
position and age 5 and so on and no no I
like wins this check I'm just getting
getting at his pawns Chan yeah there's
nothing happening anymore the briars of
course good I mean probably I should
look at this it is probably the best
line there but I'm still not entirely
convinced maybe I should really pick up
some other variation and yeah work it
out myself not just use something that
somebody else produced okay well thanks
for watching